some people in Turkey are finding it
difficult to get medicines they need
but the drugs on the shelves in this
Pharmacy are available nearly 70 percent
of them are imported
the Lira has lost more than 80 percent
of its value since 2018 and under
government schemes their price below the
market rate and mainly in Euros a
benefit for some but one that's also
created problems
because of the cost foreign suppliers
refuse to sell drugs on the government
terms it was very difficult to find
antibiotics for children in Winter for
example same goes for IVF injections
once I had to call 20 other pharmacies
to find medicine for my patient
inflation of more than 40 percent and a
rising cost of living are affecting the
lives of people across the country
in a bit to fight this turkey's Central
Bank raised interest rates to 15 from
8.5 on Thursday reversing its
unconventional policy of decreasing
borrowing costs to combat uncomfortably
High inflation
this is Turkish Central bank's First
Rate decision since president rejected
bardon's election Victory last may he
had directed his Central Bankers to cut
interest rates nine times since late
2021 when Global inflation started to
increase and most economies boosted
rates this is the first interest hike in
more than two years and Turkish Central
bank's first move after the appointment
of new governor hafez a former Goldman
Sachs banker and the first woman to hold
the job early June
for many economic experts the hike is
way below what the markets anticipated
but more gradual increases are expected
to curb inflation under what the
government calls its new economy
management
so a 15 interest rate will be very low
and that would also send a bad signal to
the economic agents in the sense that
people will think that the Central Bank
is still very reluctant towards raising
the interest rate to the required levels
is widely advocated raising interest to
tackle High inflation but turkey has
present Sac three Central Bank governors
in less than two years when they tried
to keep to Orthodox policies that's left
many wondering how far the central bank
will be allowed to go in increasing
interest rates cnco solo Al Jazeera
Istanbul